comprehensive sex education
that started with with alfred kinsey was
another pedophile and and uh and and
expressly wanted to and believe wanted
to sexualize children believe that
children are sexual literally from birth
and it's a whole story there's totally
horrifying but comprehensive
comprehensive sex education goes back to
him it starts there and so it is a from
the beginning an effort to sexualize
children to sexualize them also kind of
based in this kind of circular way on
the idea that children are already
sexual from birth
and the thing about that's so insidious
because we see that oh they're teaching
this stuff to preschoolers we find it so
shocking and it is
i mean it's horrifying but it's actually
not
surprising because well of course they
want to get to the kids that young
because when you're that when you're
four years old i mean these are the kids
who believe you know in santa claus they
like they think that spider-man is real
so
at that age psychologically they cannot
distinguish they actually cannot
distinguish between between reality and
fantasy if you go to a four-year-old
and you say to the four-year-old
superman doesn't exist they won't even
know what you mean by that doesn't mean
anything doesn't exist what do you mean
i can see him on tv i know he exists and
so that's
the left's ideas about especially about
gender are so
ridiculous and insane that they have to
get to the kids that young
at an age where they where they don't
have the mental capacity to see it for
the absurdity that it is well and if you
can indoctrinate them that young then
you get them you know potentially for
life